bonsoir nous sommes le 18 septembre il
est 18h si vous nous suivez en direct
comme chaque soir du lundi au vendredi
voici les titres pour cette édition
c'est àu qu' une école pour former les
chiens guides est en construction invité
Gilles Rossignol responsable de la
communication de l'école des chiens GUID
de Paris il nous expliquera les enjeux
autour de cette nouvelle structure
handicap toujours avec une journée de
sensibilisation organisée par la société
de transport en commun skibus accès au
bus mise en situation et échange avec
les associations 31e édition des
Journées du Patrimoine ce weekend à
cette occasion le château de Versailles
va dévoiler les trésors de l'Ile du Nord
habituellement fermé au public ce fait
d'hiver pour débuter cette édition des
affrontements ont éclaté hier enfin de
matinée à trappe les policiers sont
intervenus pour des bagarres entre
élèves du lycée Louis Blerot du gaz
lacrymogène a été utilisé par certains
jeunes les deux principaux auteurs âgés
de 16 et 17 ans ont été placés en garde
à vue je reçois ce soir donc Gilles
Rossignol bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue
responsable communication pour l'école
des chiens guides de Paris une école qui
est en chantier aussi actuellement à Buc
on va en parler mais tout d'abord
puisqu'il est question de handicap
retour sur cette opération menée
aujourd'hui par skibus société de
transport en commun à 50 ans en Yveline
et qui proposer une sensibilisation avec
des animations et des rencontres sur
place Anthony resch et William L
le temps d'une après-midi ces salariés
de la société skibus expérimentent les
sensations d'un aveugle ou encore
l'accès en fauteuil roulant et monter
dans un bus les yeux bandés pour la
toute première fois permet de ressentir
le quotidien d'une personne handicapée
c'est carrément un périple là carrément
c'est un priple pas pas évident du tout
parce que vous êtes en train de vous
comment on appelle ça chercher un repère
et que vous avez
habituellementin et là c'est un repère
inexistant au sein de l'entreprise une
formation est également proposée tous
les 15 jours au conducteurs de bus du
réseau l'objectif permettre au salariés
de savoir réagir lorsqu'une personne
handicapée souhaite monter dans le bus à
l'heure actuelle 12 lignes sur les 39
que compte le réseau skibus sont équipé
pour l'accès des personnes handicapées
pour qu'une ligne soit accessible il
faut qu'elle réponde à deux critères le
premier critère 70 % des points d'arrêt
de la ligne doit être au normes donc
avec un trottoir avec une bonne hauteur
dégager au niveau
de la de la voirie et le deuxème critère
c'est que 100 % des véhicules qui
circulent sur cette ligne doivent être
munis d'une palette une palette pour les
personnes à mobilité réduite coûte entre
6000 et 7000 € sur la communauté
d'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvel 95 %
des arrêts de bus sont dit accessibles g
rignol de l'école des chi guides de
Paris et l'invité de cette édition de
jeudi ce type d'opération qu'on vient de
voir sur la société skibus c'est une
bonne chose ça sert véritable à quelque
chose au-delà de l'animation que ça peut
représenter pour le public sur place ce
jour-là ça sert et comment je dirais
parfait j'ai même reconnu une personne
de notre réseau qui était là et je la
salue ça sert parce que c'est un point
crucial quand on a un handicap une des
premières chos qu'on va faire que ce
soit en fauteuil roulant avec un chien
guide c'est qu'on va aller prendre les
transports en commun parce qu'on
retrouve de l'autonomie et de la liberté
et sensibiliser aux personnes en
situation de handicap ça permet au
chauffeurs déjà d'être sensibilisé ça
permet aussi au public de comprendre
qu'il y a des personnes qui sont en
situation de handicap qui qui bougent
grâce au transport public euh et nous on
le fait on on le fait avec la RATP
notamment et c'est une très très bonne
initiative oui il y a des équipements
qui sont des investissements qui sont
faits pour les équipements en tout cas
parce qu'il faut des moyens pour équiper
les bus on entendait 6000 7000 € pour ce
type de passerelle les sociétés mettent
les moyens les pouvoirs publics mettent
les moyens il y a encore un frein
aujourd'hui alors sur les équipements à
proprement parler je Seris pas vous dire
euh les les transports publics mettent
des moyens sur la sensibilisation pour
notamment tous les chauffeurs et sur les
équipements vous avez le sentiment que
ça ça avance en tout cas ça progresse la
loi de 2005 partout pour tous progresse
même s'il y a eu du retard sur
l'équipement par contre des des
bâtiments publics mais là c'est
peut-être un autre sujet on va revenir
au cœur du sujet pour lequel vous êtes
là ce soir c'est pour nous parler de ce
futur centre pour chien guide d'aveugle
qui est en construction à Buc ce sera
une deuxième antenne pour votre
établissement qui est situé à Paris
structure fondée voici 25 ans pour venir
en aide au malvoyant et en le remettant
des chiens guides le constat aujourd'hui
c'est que tous les ans une centaine de
personnes encore attend un chien
justement vous n'aviez pas la capacité
la possibilité de de répondre à la
demande oui alors il faut comprendre
deux choses on est une école dans un
réseau il y a 12 écoles qui sont
fédérées au sein de la fédération
française et association chin guide
d'aveugle l'École de Paris a en réserve
ou en réservoir 120 personnes qui
attendent 120 c'est un chiffre il faut
traduire c'est entre 2 ans 2 ans et demi
3 ans d'attente pour avoir un chengy qui
est remis gratuitement ça c'est
important donc effectivement l'idée
c'est de réduire ce délai donc
d'augmenter le nombre de chien guide
remis et pour ça la nécessité de
construire on va dire une deuxième école
ou un centre d'élevage et d'éducation
donc il y a un centre à Paris et le
centre à Buc où on est le le chantier on
en voit quelques images ben le chantier
avance on a samedi dernier fait une
cérémonie la cérémonie du bouquet qu'on
va mettre en haut de la charpente donc
ça donne une bonne idée les bâtimentss
sont sortis de terre les charpentes sont
là les boxes de maternité sont là les
boxes d'éducation sont là box de famille
d'accueil aussi après il reste à faire
tout le reste donc il y a encore à peu
près on va dire 8 mois 10 mois de
travail donc ça devrait voir le jour
vers le 1emer semestre 2015 la capacité
une trentaine de chiens sur Paris une
trentaine de chiens ici aussi oui alors
c'est le centre d'élevage et d'éducation
est un centre d'élevage d'éducation donc
ça va permettre de créer des chiot donc
ça vait à peu près ça veut dire à peu
près 120 chiot par an qui naîtront à Buc
euh une trentaine de chiens
effectivement ent qui seront en période
d'éducation en première éducation à Buc
et un peu plus à Paris d'accord vous
parlez de la naissance de ces chiens
justement comment ça se passe
l'éducation concrètement d' d'un chien
guide d'aveugle tous les chiens peuvent
prétendre à devenir chien guide
d'aveugle déjà non non non non non c'est
pour ça qu'on a un sang d'élevage parce
qu'il faut sélectionner les mâles et les
femelles on fait des croisements la
plupart ce sont des retriever golden
labrador on a des Barbé on a des flat
côtes des bordeurs colis aussi donc il y
a une sélection une présélection et
ensuite on suit le chot de sa naissance
jusqu'à sa remise donc c'est un travail
24 24 pendant 2 ans donc n'importe quel
chien ne peut pas devenir ch un guide
d'aveugle d'autant qu'il faut avoir des
connaissances une expertise que l'on a
nous depuis plus d'une trentaine
d'années donc c'est vraiment un travail
bien précis et spécifique h comment se
passe la formation au quotidien pour ces
chiens alors la formation ils naissent à
l'école ils sont ils sont vaccinés au
bout de 3 mois ils partent en famille
d'accueil je voudrais bien revenir
là-dessus d'ailleurs parce qu'on a en
recherche de famille d'accueil c'est un
point essentiel pour la région ici le 78
euh ensuite il reste une petite année
avec la famille d'accueil qui commence
une prééducation en relation avec
l'école et ensuite il passe une toute
petite année à l'école d'éducation entre
les mains d'un prééducation éducation
donc c'est 2 ans de 2 ans de travail
avant d'être remis cette période de
remise dure à peu près 6 mois entre la
première rencontre et le fait que on
considère que le chien est véritablement
remis et qu' a plus besoin de
retravailler et ensuite il y a une
période de 9 ans de suivi avant la
retraite il faut ces familles d'accueil
alors c familles d'accueil consiste en
quoi allez-y c'est cette famille
d'accueil ce sont des bénévoles j'espère
vous convaincre et prendre un chin guide
à la fin deémission difficile dans
l'appartement on va faire de la place on
accepte les appartements les personnes
déficientes visuelles vivent beaucoup en
appartement en tout cas les familles
d'accueil s'investissent énormément sont
des bénévoles donc c'est gratuit entre
guillemets si ce n'est que un travail
d'à peu près 25 he par jour pour
commencer uneéducation avec ces chiens
donc ce sont des personnes investies qui
savent ce qu'elles font et surtout elles
sont suivies accompagné par l'école et
par un éducateur disponible aussi parce
qu' vous par de ce temps d' accueil les
familles qui travaillent par exemple le
chien va pas rester tout seul à la
maison c'est pas forcément on remarque
il faut pas que le chien reste seul à la
maison pas plus de 2h ou 3h ça veut dire
que la personne qui travaille elle peut
amener le chien sur son lieu de travail
il y a un décret qui existe qui rend
cette possibilité là même pour les
élèves changines qui ne sont pas encore
devenus chin Guin donc c'est vraiment la
socioabilisation au maximum et donc on
cherche des familles de manière à ce que
le chot puisse vivre de la même manière
parce ensuite il vivra avec une personne
déficiente visuelle et cette période
dure combien de temps famille d'accueil
une petite année une petite année de lâ
3 mois jusque vers 1 an du chiot ça
dépend des chiot ça dépend des RAC et ca
donc n'hésitez pas si vous souhaitez
être famille d'accueil pour pour ces
chiens pour ces chiot qui deviendront
guide d'aveugles à prendre contact avec
les chiens guides de Paris qui pourront
vous donner tous les renseignements avec
bien sûr des besoins nécessair très
important en ce moment avec l'ouverture
à venir du centre sur sur but qu'on
l'imagine vous disiez c'est remis
gratuitement ça coûte cher malgré tout
un chien guidement c'est financé oui bah
c'est financé par des dons privés des
legs et des dons euh c'est difficile de
donner un coup on donne une fourchette
une idée voilà on a on s'entend au
niveau national et avec la Fédération de
dire que c'est à peu près 25000 € ça
donne une idée c'est pas 500 € c'est pas
150000 € c'est 2 ans de travail plus 9
ans de suivi donc ça plus ensuite la
famille de retraite derrière donc c'est
15 ans de l'année d'un chien qu'on prend
quasiment en charge alors les familles
d'accueil je précise on paye les
croquettes et le vétérinaire donc c'est
entre guillemets cooup zéro la personne
déficiente visuel elle prend en charge
ces ces frais là mais voilà on arrive
sur à peu près cette fourchette là ça ça
ça donne une idée quand même de la
valeur ajoutée que l'on a l'idée étant
que derrière c'est un bénéfice
gigantesque on utilise on produit entre
guillemets des chiens guides pour un
handicap sensorial en l'occurrence la
cécité et c'est ça qu'on essaie de de de
de de vaincre en fait parce que vous
dites produire justement c'est
véritablement le terme puisqu'il y a
cette sélection aussi génétique qui qui
s'opère et qui s'opérera à Bukin dans le
cent oui c'est vraiment ça va être le le
le le le on va dire le le critère
principal de l'école on aura un centre
d'élevage on aura h maternités on aura
neuf boxes ensuite pour accueillir les
chiens qui se qui seront nés et on a un
centre famille d'accueil donc on a toute
toute cette chaîne le début en tout cas
avant de rentrer en prééducation et en
éducation une spécificité tout de même
bu est un très bel endroit donc ça va
être vraiment notre cocouning de de
maternité ça changera de Paris ça
changera de Paris en revanche c'est
vraiment l'éco de Paris c'est une entité
ce sont de deux deux lieux géographiques
derrière l'école de Paris pourquoi on
tient à l'École de Paris parce que on
produit des chiens et on éduque des
chiens urbains sont des chiens qui vont
aller dans le métro le premier sujet
illustrait parfaitement la chose ce sont
des chiens qui vont être au milieu de la
foule ce sont des chiens qui vont aller
travailler on a des personnes qui font 1
heure et de de transport en commun avec
leurs chiens qui ont des enfants et qui
vivent quasi normalement avec un chien
guide c'est ça que ça apporte le chien
guide l'autonomie la liberté al pour
bien qu'on comprenne ce qui ne sont pas
familiarisés avec tout ça le chien guide
vous le prêtez il n'est pas donné
ensuite à la personne déficiente
visuelle oui alors récupérer après non
alors le terme c'est ni prêter ni donner
le terme c'est remis il reste quand même
sous notre responsabilité et il est
suivi on a deux personnes à l'École de
Paris qui travaille à temps plein pour
suivre 320 équipes maître chien guide et
chien guide pendant 9 ans c'est-à-dire
que la personne elle va un jour
déménager se marier avoir des enfants
donc ses besoins vont évoluer ces
transports V aussi évoluer le chien
guide va devoir apprendre d'autres
destinations où aller et donc dans ce
cadre là on les suit pendant 9 ans que
deviennent les chiens après et bien les
chiens ils
finissent leur vie le mieux possible
parce qu'ils l'ont mérité parce que
c'est un chien de travail et parce qu'on
en est responsable on met au monde un
chien on en est responsable jusqu'à son
dernier souffle donc il part en principe
en famille de retraite souvent dans la
famille proche de la personne déficiente
visuelle donc la tante les parents si
c'est pas possible des fois la personne
le garde avec avec avec elle et a un
deuxième chien mais c'est plus compliqué
sinon ils vont en famille de retraite
donc c'est un autre appel on a besoin
aussi de famille de retraite de gens
alors c'est un investissement qui est
plus léger puisque le chien a à peu près
11 ans et B i jusqu'à 13 14 ans donc on
s'engage sur 3 4 ans avec un chien qui
est terriblement bien éduqué forcément
bien éduqué donc si vous voulez les
aider dans l'éducation ça c'est beaucoup
plus jeune voilà et si vous voulez
ensuite être aussi famille pour
accueillir ces chiens en fin de vie on
va dire vous pouvez aussi vous
manifester merci beaucoup d'être venu
nous expliquer le fonctionnement de
votre structure nous manquons pas de
venir vous voir à l'ouverture ce sera au
début de l'année prochaine ce centre
d'élevage pour chin guide àveugle merci
à vous merci nous ouvrons une page
économie à présent avec un dossier
consacré à l'apprentissage ce sera l'un
des thèmes du nouveau numéro de filcoo
sur notre antenne ce soir et vous allez
voir que si ce type de formation à le
vent en poup les contraintes sont
nombreuses pour les employeurs Floran
parfait son premier emploi mie n'a pas
eu besoin de beaucoup le chercher la
société où il a appris son métier
d'artisan chauffagiste l'a pris en CDD
obtenir un un job plutôt facile avec
l'apprentissage trouver une entreprise
en alternance est en revanche plus
compliqué les artisans sont soumis à de
nombreuses réglementation notamment
sécuritaire prendre un jeune s'avère
parfois plus une charge qu'une aide
réelle il faut trouver quoi parce qu'il
y en a qui sont déjà pris il y en a qui
prennent pas forcément
d'apprentis parce que ça leur coûte
cher des choses des fois c'est assez
techniqueah par exemple déjà utiliser la
disqueuse au
début j'avais pas le droit quoi vu que
c'est dangereux puis il faut bien
prendre ses précautions avant d'utiliser
mettre ses lunettes ses gants puis fait
faire très attention l'activité
notamment celle des mineurs est
particulièrement encadrée par le Code du
travail ainsi un jeune couvreur n'a pas
le droit de monter sur une échelle et un
apprenti boulanger ne peut travailler
avant 6h du matin si des dérogations
sont possibles la lourdeur
administrative freine beaucoup
d'artisans comme l'explique Laurence
bourgeois elle a pourtant embauché ses
trois derniers apprenti s'il faut
respecter toutes les règles liées à
l'apprentissage effectivement il y a des
gens qui n'ont plus envie de travailler
avec avec les jeune c'est trop difficile
la responsabilité est énorme il faut
faut bien apprendre un MTI faut bien
savoir faire quelque chose faut bien et
pour se lancer dans la vie bah il faut
tester des choses des règles lourdes à
appliquer mais pas seulement le contexte
économique explique aussi l'impopularité
de l'apprentissage dans les ivelines les
effectifs des salariés ont diminué de 22
et de 33 % au prier et second trimestre
2014 dans les travaux publics les
entreprises ont moins de commande et peu
de visibilité à long terme pour
embaucher dans ce cas difficile de
s'engager pour 2 ans avec un apprenti on
développe de plus en plus de contrats
sur 1 an c'est-à-dire sur des deuxè
années donc on fait rentrer des jeunes
en contrat de 1 an de plus en plus je
trouve que la demande a explosé ces deux
dernières années l'an dernier déjà
c'était significatif et cette année
c'est énorme cet été seul 12 % des chefs
d'entreprise envisagé d'employer des
apprentis en alter
dans ces conditions attirer des jeunes
en centre de formation et
d'apprentissage devient un vrai problème
il y a un an ces établissements
enregistraient déjà une baisse de 3 % de
leurs effectifs par rapport à
2012 économie toujours mais aussi
environnement avec ces entreprises qui
se mettent de plus en plus souvent au
vert une société propose maintenant une
solution d'écoaturage ou quand les
moutons remplacent les tondeuses c'est
un sujet de cler
Cambier ces moutons ne brouent pas dans
un champ en pleine campagne mais sur le
site d'une entreprise pour les 3000 m
Carr qui entourent son dépôt de trappe
nature est découverte à opté pour de
l'éco pâturage ces moutons remplacent la
tondeuse on va les mettre devant
l'entrepôt parce que vous avez vu l'ERB
assez haute aussi pour le mettre bien le
plus propre possible et ensuite d'ici un
à de mois on va les mettre sur l'arrière
de l'ENT ces h moutons d'auant sont
loués à une société qui passe tous les
15 jours pour les soins vétérinaires le
reste du temps ce sont les salariés de
l'entrepôt qui s'en occupent ils sont
très dociles on a envie de des caressés
même s'ils sont très peureux voilà donc
ça fait les gens ont envie de de s'y
intéresser et de venir les voir donc
voilà ça aussi un rôle social car
l'entreprise souhaite impliquer son
personnel sur chaque site une dizaine de
salariés volontaires constituent un
réseau vert ils sont chargés de
favoriser la biodiversité ici les
copaturage mais aussi des ruches ou
encore des arbres frutiers quand vous
êtes dans votre métier ce qui vous parle
c'est donner un peu de sens à ce que
vous faites donc ben de façon
intrinsèque votre métier peut vous
donner du sens mais tout ce que vous
pouvez mettre autour pour compléter et
lui donner un peu de richesse ben c'est
toujours très bienvenu vis-à-vis des
salariés autre solution pour les
entreprises transformer ces espace vert
en prairie à Orgeval la société chinarps
voulait faire de son siège social la
vitrine de ses valeurs environnementales
il y a 3 ans une belle pelouse
verdoyante occupa l'espace il y avait à
peu près de tontes par par mois ça
faisait 26 24 tones à l'année donc
c'était très polluant puisque c'était
effectivement fait de de façon
traditionnelle et puis on avait un un
vraiment un gazon vert sans vie qui
était traité avec des
pesticides et du coup on voulait donner
vie à à cette prairie l'entreprise a
signé un échocontrat avec un autre
prestataire aujourd'hui le terrain n'est
fauché que deux fois dans l'année la
dernière date du début du mois on
retrouve une vingtaine de variétés de
plantes indigènes alors des plantes
indigènes c'est des plantes qu'on na pas
été cherché partout en France c'est
vraiment des plantes qu'on retrouve
localement dans tous nos jardins dans
tous les espaces verts qu'on peut
retrouver en région parisienne du
géranium sauvage aubleué pour les autres
espaces verts aussi les produits
phyosanitaires sont bannis on utilise
des copos de bois issus des coupes
d'arbres ça un double effet d'une part
sur les mauvaises herbes et aussi sur la
l'aspect irrigation étant donné qu'on
nirrigue plus du tout on AR plus du tout
nos nos espaces verts pour aller plus
loin des ruches ont été installées et
les abeilles ne sont pas les seules à
être protégées cet hôtel à insectes est
un abri pour de multiples espèces en cas
d'intempérie la société ne compte pas
s'arrêter là un potager est à
l'étude sport une nouvelle fois la
grande classique paris-vailles a fait le
plan sur les réservations 25000 coureurs
qui vont s'élancer le dimanche 28
septembre de la Tour Eiffel le président
de l'association a dévoilé les
spécificités de l'édition 2014 un
parcours qui reste inchangé entre le
départ au pied de la Tour Effel la
célèbre Côte des gardes à Medon et le
finish le final Royal sur l'avenue de
Paris face au châau de Versailles les
participants pourront profiter du
paysage mais pas question de laisser des
déchets Paris-Versailles s'inscrit de
plus en plus dans le développement
durable notamment concernant les puces
chronométriques des
coureurs nous on fait en sorte que cette
puce elle soit récupérée
réutilisée via le circuit des
industriels réutilisé vers d'autres
courses cet argent qu'on récupère par la
la la revente je dirais du système à
l'industriel cet argent le redistribue
avec à l'ONF et avec l'ONF on a un
projet de de construction ou
d'aménagement d'une zone en for de Medon
propos tenu au micro d'Antony reche les
journées du patrimoine 31e édition ce
weekend de nombreux monuments ouverts au
public parfois même l'occasion de
découvrir des lieux inédits après le
succès de l'ouverture de l'aile du Midi
l'an dernier le château de Versailles va
présenter les espaces et les collections
historiques de l'aile d'un Aurélia Deiss
cette année encore les Journées du
Patrimoine sont l'occasion d'ouvrir de
nouvelles portes du château de
Versailles ce weekend deux étages de
l'aile du Nord dévoileront les espaces
et collections des galeries du château
un musée historique créé par
LouisPhilippe en 1830 dédié à toutes les
gloires de la France alors là vous allez
découvrir euh au premier étage des
peintures surtout espèce de grande
présentation du règne de Louis XIV
depuis son enfance jusqu'à sa mort donc
la grande figure de Versailles et ici au
second étage nous avons des salles
consacrées en fait à la pratiquement au
19e siècle après Napoléon c'est-à-dire
depuis le retour des Bourbons sur le
trône en
1814-115 avec les deux restaurations et
jusqu'à la Première Guerre mondiale donc
un siècle d'histoire de France une
partie de l'histoire de France évoquée
par des tableaux officiels et portraits
commandés par les différents régimes qui
se sont succédés ou bien offerts par des
familles désirant s'inscrire dans
l'histoire de France les journées du
patrimoine au château de Versailles sont
donc l'occasion de voyager à travers ces
collections méconnues du grand public la
plupart des visiteurs de Versailles
ignorent totalement en fait qu'il y a ce
musée historique qui est en quelque
sorte caché derrière la la résidence
royale c'est comme la partie immergée en
fait d'un iceberg puisque les
collections historiques de versaill sont
un ensemble absolument énorme que
LouisPhilippe avait installé dans tout
le château et petit à petit la résidence
royale a reconquis certains espaces les
appartements historiques mais il y a
toujours de très nombreuses salles
historiques que nous avons donc
l'occasion de montrer pour les Journées
du Patrimoine en attendant de pouvoir
les montrer plus plus souvent plus
facilement plus normalement en fait au
public d'ici on espère quelques années
une visite inédite à découvrir
gratuitement samedi et dimanche de 9h à
17h Versailles ou Paris quel sera votre
programme pour ces journées du
patrimoine qui approche c'est notre
question du jour vos réponses au micro
de William
l pour le moment rien je suis pas là je
vais faire les vendanges dans le vosus
euh je sais pas mais j'avoue que
j'aurais bien visiter quelque chose avec
mes potes j'avais vu m si c la première
année qu'ils ouvraent leur PES et je
pense que ça va être intéressant d'
aller aucune
idée Rambouillet voilà qu'est-ce que
vous allez faire enambouillet le château
oh mon dieu ben pas grandchose parce que
il y a toujours une queue insensée pour
aller voir les monuments et je peux pas
tellement rester deou longtemps très
longtemps mais il y a plein de choses
très intéressantes à voir et si vous
manquez d'idées le programme complet est
en tout cas retrouver sur notre site
internet dans la rubrique replay plî
pour revoir le dernier numéro de notre
magazine culture kiosque en attendant
culture toujours pour terminer le
journal avec l'ouverture ce jeudi du
festival tout mélé à mole festival qui
entend favoriser la multiplicité des
formes d'expression artistiqu et dont
vous allez découvrir la bande annonce
juste le temps de vous rappeler que le
journal revient demain aux mêmes
horaires comme chaque vendredi nous
ferons un point sur l'essentiel de la
semaine nous parlerons aussi de
l'actualité du jour très bonne
[Applaudissements]
soirée
même pas fa fois pour rien je t'ai quand
même pas imaginé nu fois pour rien jeand
même
[Musique]
pas
in fait alors jeite de ma vie que
je
il existe un endroit où les hommes
parlent comme les
oiseaux